un aparente hecho terrorista esa es la
línea de investigación a la que apunta
el servicio de seguridad de la policía
de noruega tras el ataque con arco y
flecha en la pequeña localidad de
kongsberg una hipótesis firme pero no
definitiva a la espera de más pesquisas
no hay dudas de que el hecho en sí
parece un acto de terror pero es
importante ahora que la investigación
continúe y que podamos establecer el
motivo del imputado
sixt ets el atacante fue identificado
como un hombre de 37 años habitantes del
lugar y converso al islam radicalizado
las autoridades confían en que actuó
solo pero mantienen el nivel de alerta
en moderado un vecino lo describe como
solitario no
bailo nunca sonreía no mostraba nada
solo observaba sin una mirada amistosa
lucía un poco enojado y siempre lo veía
solo o así es eso
mientras tanto en la ciudad de 25.000
habitantes las banderas se lucieron a
media asta en homenaje de las víctimas y
muchos se acercaron a dejar ofrendas en
su honor
creo que es un poco difícil de asimilar
y muchos están en shock es irreal que
esto haya pasado en nuestra ciudad real
y c's madre
y pido amor a mi lista
quería mostrar mi simpatía y empatía con
todos los afectados en la ciudad y en
noruega porque esto nos afecta a todos
el hecho también ocupó el traspaso de
poder en noruega tras recibir el cargo
de su predecesora erna solberg el nuevo
primer ministro el laborista jonas gahr
store es calificó el episodio de acto
monstruoso y se solidarizó con las
víctimas